whoa this is legit high  i'm scared me too but i'm done letting  fear stop me from living  she just finished chemo a couple weeks  ago i'm not sure ella's ready for school  tomorrow we discussed this and santa and  her winds are blowing i didn't catch  cancer from the wind so i'm guessing  it's not gonna bring it back  ella come on  i finally get to be a regular teenage  girl staying up all night eating candy  drinking soda and i didn't hear any of  that  all your adventurousness has really  rubbed off on me  that is a side effect of my friendship  [Music]  [Applause]  today i'm alive  and i don't plan on shying away from  anything  [Applause]  forget yesterday i want to make some new  memories  don't hit me with any of that meditation  joke hey that junk works  [Music]  you